hey gang it's your old pals uncle hank
and the kipster
make sure you subscribe to the youtube
page that way you get the videos
as they come out welcome to another
exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast
this is our u garbage gang it's the show
we sit down with your favorite comedians
we found they go up classy
or if they're a big old piece of trash
i'm your host states foley coming at you
on a beautiful day
down here aunt cody's basement in the
big studio
down here in the heart of midtown
manhattan my co-host is coming at you
from across the table at me so you know
what that means gang
it's a little [ __ ] family time you
can play with your friends later
right now we're having family time we're
gonna do a couple patreon questions
a couple of questions from the facebook
group a couple of questions from the
squad out there
ladies and gentlemen give me a big round
of applause for our old pal
the chairman of the board the ceo of are
you garbage
he's on the manifest main staff man
staff what's it called
i don't know you keep asking me somebody
somebody answered the other day god damn
it goddamn add
kevin james ryan hey what's up everybody
thanks for tuning in
as always please make sure you rate
review subscribe on itunes the full
video
it is available on youtube yes those
numbers are
true to [ __ ] roof dude [ __ ]
burning and turning on
free christmas trees when you subscribe
if you do listen at least go
check out if you do just if you do
listen on itunes or stitcher or spotify
whatever just go drop us a sub on
youtube you know what i mean get those
numbers up the [ __ ] production
quality from t-bone
is through the [ __ ] roof we're
putting out some [ __ ] high-quality
[ __ ] i'm talking about over here
uh also we're talking heavy bike you go
to patreon.com
are you garbage guys the support on
patreon has been fantastic that helps us
keep the [ __ ] lights on that helps us
[ __ ]
put a little bit of walking around cash
in our pocket you know what i mean
um so you can go there you can get bonus
content you get bonus episodes you can
get videos you can get live streams or
at the end of every month
we play uh are you garbage with the
listener you know what i mean we ask you
questions you ask us
questions it's a whole [ __ ] thing
it's gonna be a good time go sign up
support the [ __ ] boys
that's [ __ ] it i like it yeah thanks
for tuning in you guys take care now
[Laughter]
real tragically obligated to do two
minutes peace
real quick just want to give a nice
special shout out kevin mentioned this
gentleman before
he's the [ __ ] pride of the chicago
comedy chicago
he's a good pal of ours he's the [ __ ]
magic man
you all know him as t-bone but his mama
called him
toby mcmullen everybody what up t-bone
t-bone you better close that window or
you're not getting paid this month man a
few
by the way you ever know anybody that
got oil i i didn't whoa
that that thing stunk dude that's weird
too and also we didn't have it i
remember
my buddy my buddy we were over his house
and like they didn't have water for
literally yeah shut down they're like
i'm like why they're like
they're fixing the well i'm like the wet
i just
i was like seven so i didn't know and
i'm like what the [ __ ] you got a whole
like i thought that
i didn't i still don't understand it to
be honest with you i don't get it
all i know is i turn the sink and i got
some [ __ ] watercolor i know i
all i know i'm hooked up to a main we
ain't pulling out of a well i ain't got
a bucket a rope
no i know well water can go bad real
quick wipe out a whole village i don't
[ __ ] with that i don't know what it is
that happened uh to my aunt and uncle
went over to their place and they were
like
the whale's gone bad so it'll just be
diet cokes for the kids
sign me up let me go that sounds like a
good time but i remember taking a shower
with diet coke
gives me good volume in my hair uh
yeah i didn't i never under i still
don't understand that
how's it filtered then i don't know man
i'm sure i'm sure somebody out there it
doesn't seem smart to like every
every house has a well that you then
have to fill is that what happened i
don't know if we
we want to know so if you're one of our
listeners and you're a hillbilly
throw us a [ __ ] comment or wherever
you consume the podcast
yeah listen if you don't have lead
poisoning
you still have your sight there's no way
you got a cell phone and well warner
i don't know mike my my uh what's it my
what's my sister-in-law's brother called
to me
a dumbass [ __ ] [ __ ] i don't know
if you do have a well and a cell phone
it's 100 clipped to your belt
or you share it with the neighbor the
phone he has uh
but he lives up in the mountains and he
gets water from like from running on the
mountain and like they have like a
little thing
it almost looks like something where you
get holy water in like vatican city it
just comes out and has a little spigot
and it's just constantly running i've
done that i don't trust it
when i was what if somebody takes a dump
at the top of the mountain
that happens but it's you know i mean
there's just a dead deer in there or
something
dead deer in here or something did you
sound like such a [ __ ] hillbilly
what is your dead deer in here they get
gangrene
they deer in my living room um i
actually
uh i was in uh switzerland a few years
ago and we climbed up the you know we
went like on a hike all the way up the
thing and that
it was like a [ __ ] strenuous hike and
that was the water you just filled up an
empty box
dude i'm telling you're [ __ ]
thousands of feet uh it's [ __ ]
screaming cold
and it's coming right from an ice cap so
it's like dude you just fill it up in
the
little waterfall and i'm telling you i
was like yeah
you don't realize it and then that's
what i drank for two days
and then we got back to the car and i'm
like dude and i opened up a bottle
like a plastic bottle of [ __ ] poland
spring or something you could taste the
chemicals
i've said it was bad news i've said this
before
now obviously i'm a fat piece of [ __ ] i
eat yeah you look pretty good i'm
working on it
but i'm a big water guy all right i'm a
big
pellegrino guy big mineral water guy and
i saw this thing on netflix
that uh zach uh efron yeah oh that yeah
not a bad looking
kid that dude's got a [ __ ] body on it
hey
little body yeah he makes me feel funny
i gotta be honest
makes me feel good my wife's like let's
watch that zac efron thing i'm like nah
i think i've seen it already
i'm not watching it with you yeah i like
to watch it in the beach
you're sleeping
doing a little pulley pulley oh yeah but
now they talked all about different
water and different mineral content
solid content and all that stuff i love
all that stuff all most of the [ __ ] that
we drink
sucks minerals out of our body
apparently because if you drink water
that doesn't have a certain amount of
mineral content
it [ __ ] takes the minerals out of
your body
sounds like a [ __ ] superman villain
yeah
mineral man i don't know but just like
we're gonna make the water steal stuff
from them
that's what zach was telling me he
seemed like he knew what he was doing
could have been those pectoral muscles i
don't know either way that's neither
here nor there gang this is a patreon
episode this is a patreon question
episode
all right hold on before because you
clearly don't know what you're talking
about it's in everything episode
of the hard feelings everybody
i love how you break my balls off camera
about content and you don't even know
what we're doing welcome back to ykkwd
yeah we're in the
we're in the middle of an episode he
literally doesn't even know what he's
recording
you're like you're like [ __ ] you're
singing though who gives a [ __ ] you're
like ron burgundy you'll just say
anything on the teleprompter the show's
started
the lights are on go i don't i don't
memorize lines i memorize colors green
blue red you know to be funny if an
airplane story get out there and tell an
operating story all right tom cruise
ain't coming
shout out to louis i thought you were a
news man
um this is a fan question episode we are
taking some questions
from the patreon as you know if you sign
up for patreon you're guaranteed to get
a question
asked on the air at some point we're
working through them also we're taking
some from the facebook group today
and the general pop yeah it's a family
up it's a family
i want everybody to feel included we
want to include everybody and there's
just so
guys it's so fun i [ __ ] love it i
love the fact that we're doing two
episodes a week
because we're just you know we get
guests we get to do you know answer your
questions with guests we get to do it
with me and him there's so many [ __ ]
good questions we get thousands
of [ __ ] submissions for questions
that are all most of them are fantastic
some of them are real [ __ ] snoozers
kind of work on your right yeah and some
of you guys are real [ __ ] trash
dude by the way some of the questions
you asked i think you're gonna kill your
sister
that only happens in jail you ever get
mad at the warden for changing the
for changing the tater tots i'm like
what are you [ __ ] relax pal
this is a [ __ ] fun show
um no but so we got a [ __ ] list of
some [ __ ] bangers we're gonna do a
couple from the facebook group if you're
not in the facebook group join that
that's [ __ ] i mean that's like those
kids are wild man that's a community
they're [ __ ]
out of control it's great people are
posting pictures [ __ ] on each other it's
all fun lighthearted stuff
dying dying laughing
yeah okay let's get into some of these
here um it's the fall it's that time of
the year
this is from scott dopey doperian dope
something i don't know
scott [ __ ] italian guy you proofread
these uh
no i'm just winging it all right all
right um did any
did anyone's folks used to burn leaves
did you do that
burn leaves a certain day of the week
because it was permitted
they do it all right so if you're from
like in the suburban areas especially in
the northeast when it fall hits
there's leaves everywhere some townships
will they come close everywhere
is an understatement it's out of [ __ ]
control and i worked at a landscaping
company for a long time
yeah that was a brutal part of the year
but it's so satisfying once you have it
fall cleanups
oh come on i used to have to rake it i
used to [ __ ] my dad was a [ __ ]
whack oh dude if there was one piece of
[ __ ] leaf out there
i was hearing it now you know why i'm a
little hot strong
my parents literally cut down every tree
in their yard
so they wouldn't have to worry about
leaving that's garbage stuff my brother
did that my brother came in and cleared
[ __ ] house but my neighbors they
don't give a [ __ ] so it blows all over
their lawn so every fall i gotta hear my
old man bitching about the neighbor
yeah that's a big uh we didn't burn them
per se but people in the neighborhood
did yeah it was like tuesday
night at nine you would have to burn
them made the neighborhood smaller
real good out there smoking a j hey
light up if you guys smoke them if you
got them my man
this is like a northeastern maple right
here
smoking a doobie a little bit of
hawaiian [ __ ] jambalaya let's go
um we did the biggest thing was [ __ ]
making a pile and jumping out of a tree
i could still smell it being in there oh
i can feel it on you i can
smell it i can [ __ ] do it i miss
dude there was something about the
quietness when you were down under all
the leaves
it was just kind of like the rest of the
world was blacked out a little bit
psycho come out of there with a couple
ticks oh yeah
a couple of rolly pollies in your ear a
couple of daddy long leggers man
hey we get you that was big jumping in a
leaf pile
you've ever ripped the legs off a daddy
long legger you're garbage
i'm not afraid of daddy long legs i'm
scared of any spider it's so funny my
wife
we went into the woods and we went into
like a cabin and there was you know it's
like a [ __ ] cabin in the middle of
the woods there's daddy long layers
spiders everywhere and she goes well
what is
she's like look at that one she's like
what's that called i'm like a daddy when
you try to explain a daddy long leg to
somebody that's never heard the name
daddy
it's so trashy um she's like is that the
name of it i'm like
i think so scientific i don't know but
i'm a 34 year old man who calls them
daddy longleggers daddy longlegger
holy [ __ ] daddy long legs not leger
where the [ __ ] are you
mountain top pennsylvania long legger
baby yeah
a couple of daddy long leggers dlls baby
daddy long leggers also
also my name for my [ __ ] uh uh this
is
four loco pounders calling a little
couple daddy long legs so why
put uncle hank sleep poison me
i call him spider bites put me out tranq
dart when you're on the south end of an
eight ball
yeah i need that um yeah that was big
man i [ __ ]
love that dude if i could just jump into
a leaf pile and not break an elbow or
something right now
yeah sometimes when i go home i'll just
i'll kneel down on the grass and i'll
just smell the grass just to smell
you know my childhood smell the earth
you lay down in the grass
[Music]
purposefully or you'd fall over trying
to tie your fuel play it cool
no no i'm smelling down again
yeah get out of here no yeah i'll bend
over and smell it i like walking in the
grass in my bare feet too it's very
important very good for you yeah i feel
grounded yes that's what it is connected
to mother gaia that was from scott on
patreon we appreciate it scott you're
trash man
sorry dude but it is pretty cool i've
driven out to like uh
i was you know connecticut and just like
upstate and stuff when you get out there
and it's just like a farm and they just
got a fire going and they're just like
they're just burning whatever the [ __ ]
they got love it it's cool yeah
um we had a bonfire at theater school
behind the farm farmhouse we used to
burn [ __ ] like burn the old sets and
stuff like that like a bonfire
it's [ __ ] great merv griffin said
um this is from john rowe in the
facebook group have you ever
this one hit hit so close to home for me
can i pause for a second you can pal you
do you cover up your camera with your
little piece of tape
uh yeah yeah is that that's a real thing
i thought that was a conspiracy thing
no it's for sure real who's looking at
you i don't know who's looking at me but
if someone hacks you they can turn your
camera on
man toby's chiming in i think yeah
[ __ ] zuckerberg does it that's how
you know what's really yeah he covers
his one huh that's why i do it
and his mic dude yeah jesus don't care
if i hear me
i don't care if you hear me jerking off
but don't look at me i've got a little
people
uh no well let's okay so for the
listener i'm a big bath man i like
taking baths
to relax have a glass of wine maybe a
little bit of scotch
you know i'm a big bath i draw a me and
toby's dining
jesus christ relax kid will you chicago
laughing like a prospector
all right you're going to try to squeeze
that impression in use it ykwd
um and i got i take my computer in i
watched some seinfeld
and i don't i you got the [ __ ] i'm
looking at the things looking at me
floating around in the tub with my
little man-made
[ __ ] floating around so i cover it up
where do you put that in the tub
you don't have a little a little bathtub
tv tray do you
uh no sometimes i'll put it on the
toilet seat or sometimes there's like
i'll take in a little
uh a table can you can you please do
tubby time with can't be on patreon oh
my god that's perfect
correct 100 that's my new [ __ ] thing
tubby time with kippy
sign up now guys just for the listener i
wear bad man nipples
i wear a shirt and underwear
and ear muffs for some reason no i'll
definitely do it from the neck up
everybody
from the neck
yeah dude i do for sure i do candles i
[ __ ]
you know my wife will do some salts or
some oils and stuff i get it going
can you guys both fit in the tub
together yeah we're not you you can
yeah you can both fit in the tub mm-hmm
what kind of tub do you have
and can i get a white one i don't know
yeah it's a tub
who knows the brand of their tub in
their new york city it's not like i
designed the band does it have the
things in the bottom the legs is like a
big basin tub
no that's those are old schools yeah i
want one of those i need one of those
with the lion's feet yeah i don't fit in
the tub
yeah i'll i'll ring you out my mom's
jacuzzi she's got a jacuzzi really yeah
did she come with it no she doesn't
coming to uh a patreon near you very
nice
um this is from john rowe this hit me so
[ __ ] close to home have you ever used
box fans in your windows
as an intake or exhaust dude do you
remember that one summer where i didn't
have air condition i was like really
hemmed up on money like really bad i had
quit my day job
you lived in astoria no no no no i lived
in uh there was a time there
you were on like the fourth floor i was
in that i was in my old apartment
by my side i just moved in i quit my job
at the law firm
my wife was still in germany and
i was [ __ ] i had like nine dollars to my
name
no ac dude i was putting i was running
the
it was like 500 degree i was like having
hallucinations and [ __ ] in the middle of
the night
and all i could afford was a 19 exhaust
fan that i put in the window
to try to blow [ __ ] 104 degree air on
you
it was tough box fans suck put them on
the ground they fall over
yeah that's tough you gotta prop it up
against something but they can get like
a laundry basket
when they hit number three that's like a
[ __ ] turbo jet
yeah i've 100 had that in the window
yeah
real garbage dude if you if you're
walking by and you look up you see a
[ __ ] box fan in a window
you are struggling somebody's struggling
the only thing worse than that is the
thing that looks like an air conditioner
but it's just a fan
it like goes in like uh toby knows what
i'm talking about oh what's the two with
the twos
but the two in take it out the [ __ ] out
who are you
put some ice in it that shit's garbage
the ultimate is for a little while we
had a fan in our living room when i was
a kid that didn't have a front grate on
it
oh you had to be real careful they were
big in the 80s and 90s to lose a finger
oh no it was supposed to have a glass no
i know but yeah it fell
off it's just broke i feel like things
were more expensive
back like things we didn't replace
things as easily as you replace things
they were made here now everything's
made in china and it's real cheap
i guarantee your fan was made in [ __ ]
china in the 80s and 90s
usa um but
i feel like we just had broken [ __ ]
around the house that we've just always
used
dude now if like my remote wasn't
working i would have a new one in
[ __ ] but you know
you know you're not a divorced mom with
a family of three she had cat there was
some cash
she was getting broken off i remember
those [ __ ] i'd have to give the check
to my [ __ ] mom sometimes for my dad
it was late usually but that thing was
all right
yeah i yeah three g's no a little less
no a little
per per kid though what she had to pay a
pr it was a price you got three checks
well one check but for three kids wow
and then when the kid hit 18
they [ __ ] phased out now is that
court determined
yeah so he didn't just do it on the
goodness of his heart
no but he paid for everything like you
know
do you think that if he was in court
order he wouldn't have paid for anything
for you
no he would have paid for everything did
he pay for you to go to college
uh some um things were a little
thing funds were tight when i went to
college my sister got paid in full
i think my brother did everything i
think my brother did as well but then uh
by the time meat had rolled around oh
man that's what i said to my sister like
we had completely different [ __ ]
upbringing she had like she turned 16
she got like a brand new car
a cell phone i'm like babe it was
[ __ ] bone dry by the time i
by the time i became a teenager the fun
times were over
it was like cars getting ready go kart
and a walkie talkie dude remember the
floor was undone for like two years
uh it was like i don't know what was
happening
i stopped staying there t get to the
foleys tomorrow oh yeah
under construction for the page oh
that's that's a good plug for the
patreon uh we hit our first goal of 300
patrons i think that was it right 250
250 we had our first goal 250. we hit
our first goal of 250 patrons
so uh we're doing an mtv crib style
[ __ ] invasion of the foley household
what we've been trying to do but the
covenant
the kovid's been jamming us off people
have got a [ __ ] isolate quarantine
that whole thing but we're going
tomorrow we got the [ __ ] go ahead
we're going to
throw it back i don't want to be on
camera though i talked no
throw a bag of doritos in the backyard
and let them do savages
[Laughter]
put some sleeping pills in some lunch
meat we're going to have to get some
cell phone video of them or oh i'll get
them there's going to be some sneaky
i'll get a body cam they won't know
what's happening i'll tell them i'm a
cop they're very staunch they don't want
to be on camera uh
my mother said quote i don't want to be
on your television show on the tv
network
[Laughter]
talk about out of touch now i know where
you get it how do you stay so sharp
[Laughter]
uh i love you mommy you're the best
mommy ever yeah they could be like foley
are you wearing a wire it's a laugh
[Laughter]
i ain't no rat um okay this is from
uh also from facebook this is from mike
smith might be an alias
mikey very generic name
uh do you ever uh
i feel like foley uh you ever start
eating food from your cart in the
grocery store before you pay for it
no i was never a big on that i don't
like eating in public and i thought that
was really trashy
and i'm such a [ __ ] that i was always
scared that i was gonna get in trouble
for doing that
and my mom really didn't even do it you
know what i mean
um she's got a rotisserie chicken open
she's making mac and cheese in the back
making making chicken salad you guys got
a hot plate i can use
nah she wasn't big on that i mean i'll
taste the grape oh yeah what are you a
[ __ ] yeah of course yeah i'll taste
the grape but that's about it
it's something about that no good might
you never never slug a naked juice pop
it on a shelf
no i don't like stealing catholic guilt
yeah i don't
stealing little shits no good that's not
the garbage way yeah
um steal big [ __ ] i think i might have
told you
when my mom i think when my brother was
working at the giant food store stole
lunch meat no
she got oh yeah yeah yeah i think i got
into it yeah so it's a whole thing but
she was
oh i guess because they grew up so poor
and [ __ ] like it was always a point of
pride that she never stole anything
that that was pan it was like you do not
[ __ ] i don't care if you don't have
the money and you can't pay
the credit card you don't steal you
don't steal
never steal little [ __ ] um only go big
maseratis
back in beamers yeah you know you find
20 bucks on the ground you try to give
it back you find 12k
on the ground you were with your kids
all night
right we were big on i died you know i
was a big uh
big roll guy growing up we would go to
the super fresh [ __ ] weird kid in
[ __ ]
richborough pennsylvania and i would
with [ __ ] shut you up
right to the deli get a [ __ ] soft
amoroso roll dude and just [ __ ]
sit in the cart and crush that thing ugh
crush it
maybe only finish half of it put the
other half in the front pouch of my
starter jacket
who knows wait you were wearing a
starter jacket and you still
fit into the [ __ ] front of the cart
maybe the back of the cart you mean like
just in the cart that's real
we weren't allowed to do that that's
like right in the back of a pickup truck
oh which we did you sit you sit oh yeah
but you sit in the
in the little cart thing when you're a
little kid yeah when did you get this we
were never in the car
stepping on the groceries and [ __ ] like
that i mean i wasn't like [ __ ]
jumping around making [ __ ] wine or
anything
i was [ __ ] sitting down chilling
cruising oh man
yeah often like you'll never have that
safety and security again
sitting in the [ __ ] grocery cart
while your mom pushes you around
cook the snacks up for the week yeah
feeling like a badass because you're not
strapped in
that's for the [ __ ] kimmy doesn't
need to be straight i'm never crying
being put in that thing though
i wanted a walker yeah your legs didn't
fit gotten off to circulation
hey ma i can't feel my toes need a
diastolic over here
all right all right let's see what else
good good [ __ ] so
no never never eat anything in the
grocery store
yeah a little bit well oh my dad always
my dad i would always get a sample
of the lunch meat oh i was sliced so
crazy and they hold it up and my dad
would [ __ ]
for sure well he didn't ask for it
because
they do it behind the deli hey can you
slice that then they pull it here you go
oh yeah like is this good and he goes
yeah to go here you go yeah
yeah yeah yeah man shout out to [ __ ]
acme they want a great ship
i tell you of all the things there was
nothing better than my mom getting back
from the grocery store on a saturday it
had to be a saturday
and it was early maybe before five
o'clock mass before dinner who knows
what dinner was gonna be
but there'd be a nice lunch immediately
of the fresh cold cuts that she got dude
with the fresh [ __ ] rolls fresh rolls
fresh pickles
a [ __ ] brand new bag of chips and an
ice cold
[ __ ] she'd crack open the [ __ ] two
liter a coke or pepsi
fill up some [ __ ] football glass with
ice
i had faded paint on it from the
dishwasher oh man
[ __ ] nothing better than that yeah
the family just we were like
eating lunch meat goldfish i would put
the goldfish on a [ __ ]
on a turkey and cheese oh my god yeah
did i still do that when i go home
i can't buy goldfish at the house
because they literally the last 10
seconds
10 seconds i'll mulch i'll mulch a
[ __ ] [ __ ] more so than a cheez-it
yeah cheez-its are a little denser i'll
do a whole box of cheeses
without even thinking about it i started
i'll [ __ ] do it right now i'll do
cheez-its but i buy the little box not
the pounder
they have like the big one-pound box but
they have now they have like a tinier
one yeah
they also have big cheez-its now they're
like they're like big ones like a
[ __ ] couch cushion
yeah i go for the ogs yeah what am i a
[ __ ] i told you a bit of toasty the
extra toasty ones are [ __ ] a-okay
that's like i guess they burn a batch
and they were like yo these are pretty
good throw them in a box change the
label
ah let's say you know you're trash you
like them burnt like a burnt hot dog do
you
oh yeah for sure a little crazy i
remember my stepmom
she was like i like mine a little burnt
and that blew my mind i'm like you like
your hot dogs burnt
and then little kippy had to try good
night
there's crispy on the outside garbage in
the middle
oh yeah how do you you're at home alone
you're looking for a hot dog how are you
cooking microwave what am i [ __ ]
you're
alone you're looking i don't care if the
[ __ ] queen of england's at my house
i'm microwaving an oscar meyer chief
yeah man you're trying to grow
[ __ ] buns with some [ __ ] pretzels
some chips or some goldfish on the side
as a kicker
that's crazy to me what are you fully
are you microwaving
i'm eating it raw yeah i'm [ __ ]
microwaving it for sure
how are you cooking a hot dog i'm a
working mom i'm on board with timing
there's only one way to cook a hot dog
how toaster oven
this guy this guy [ __ ] out what happened
what happens when you get outside of
ohio who the [ __ ] knows
boy wait this is the king of the midwest
wackos
and for all the listeners i'm going to
change your life right now it's gotta
take what 40 minutes in a toaster
no no no no it takes like one toast
cycle quick no but the key is the key is
this is gonna change your life forever
you gotta spiralize it i get that hey
ron popeil
no no i'm trying to fight i'm trying to
watch my three's company over here no
shot you take a couple of new
rules around the edge you get it gets it
crispy on the inside and the outside
toaster oven three four minutes
un unbelievable dude four minutes kippy
unbelievable
is that bobby flay over there yeah
what's up bobby hey wolfgang bobby
hey wolfgang [ __ ] yourself [ __ ] that
now uh in the house by myself bad things
happen
as far as food-wise things i wouldn't
want people to know what i could
imagine oh it ain't good especially at
my mom how are you
doing pretty good yeah we're doing
actually oh that's
good oh dude you couldn't even get
through that
i'm doing good i quit smoke i'm not
smoking
well you weren't eating the cigarettes
i'm not smoking i'm on the nicotine gum
okay i'm not done anything else i'm not
drinking i'm not doing anything
um and we're eating you know we're
eating three meals a day a little bit of
snack but we're walking a lot we're
doing a lot of walking we go to the park
we walk over there
okay i make sure i get up every morning
now and i can save the weight challenge
for the patreon
you know what i mean that's paige you're
doing okay garbage good i'm glad to hear
now the holidays are coming up oh man
you know you got to live a little bit
around the holidays
especially with the covers you don't
you've lived enough around every day
yeah you've eaten enough pizza for
[ __ ]
an army
i couldn't get that hey wolf can't go
[ __ ] yourself huh
you know you know what sucks remember
that remember that for a minute ago
that one remember when kippy got that
punchline put it in the promo
um you know what sucks is i've i've
recently wreaked it's sad
because you know there's certain things
that i just can't do anymore that i
really tie your shoes
come on that was good yeah what that's
why i i'm i was having a hard time tying
my shoes
and putting my socks on but i found a
trick for fat guys
to put to put your socks on slingshot
[Laughter]
boomerang what are we talking here
pulley system what do you got
to put my socks on by using the bed i'll
do a video and i'll show you yeah there
you go patreon
put it on patreon this is really patreon
plug heavy i've
i've um i've really rekindled my love
affair with the sicilian slice
when just over the last year like
in the summer yeah we're all cheesy i'm
being serious in the summer i'm joking i
didn't look at the camera
we're having a good time here we're all
right i'm just saying i really
i really like sicilian pizza and that's
really big yeah
i peg you for a cauliflower pizza kind
of guy i would eat that i like
cauliflower
i had cauliflower fried rice the other
day crystal made it was nice
great it was good stuff little peas
little stuff like that
great but the more i think about it the
sicilian is my slice and
makes me because it's bigger yeah i
don't know it's just crispier it's
crunchier on the bottom
it's it's what i think about what pizza
should be
you hear that folks when you're
pre-diabetics
you don't see any sicilians with
diabetes i'll tell you that
all right let's get back to the [ __ ] i
apologize we're having fun
hope you guys are having fun this is
from the one and only
mr zach amico
big guy big on the midnight spook show
the midnight spook show of guests real
ass podcast
shout out to zach shout out to zakamiko
we love you buddy he raised the question
is a
tattoo on a girl's titty meat like
animal paws on either boob or anything
that's solely
on the titty meat that shows with
cleavage a sign of is that a sign of
pure garbage
yeah right i almost spit up a little bit
that was like eve had the two
[ __ ] dog prince which is pretty hot
when they're tight yeah but like when
you see like somebody's aunt that has
like
you know stephanie and like tattooed on
there or like an anchor or something
who's your hand popeye what the [ __ ] it
was that it was in cursive and now it's
stretched out and it's regular print
yeah anything in cursive looks real bad
yeah it doesn't age well
no i'm thinking about getting a tattoo
right here just slice a sicilian
ain't nobody quicker than kippy that's
not a bad idea you get a [ __ ] slice
of sicilian
no but i am thinking about an attempt on
my forearm right there i love how you
make a muscle like that's really yeah
yeah ah that's personal
i can't afford i can't personally a
friend who passed away that's what i was
thinking about putting his name on there
ah
yeah do i know this friend of course you
yeah
you know all my friends i'm your only
friend they're all dying
buddy i'm all you got i've been doing it
hey take a look around your inventory is
pretty like i'm
doing a little stock check on friends i
don't really have anybody that i can
call and chit chat with
and i'm a big chit chat guy every once
in a while
do you see a common denominator in all
these
you're painful to talk to off the
podcast
ah i think you need to do a little soul
searching i'm doing something get
yourself get yourself a
sicilian pie and walk on the beach for a
little bit it really takes some time to
reflect
love sicilian pizza um this is from
daddy dub
fresh on patreon and with this you know
this is a little bit tired
uh you know tired ground we've gone over
it but a lot of we have a lot of new
listeners and stuff like that so
oh yeah and we're coming up on the
holiday season oh yeah
um this is artificial trees or
or real christmas trees hands down
[ __ ] come on
what is this are you garbage 101 over
here we're [ __ ] juniors
it's trash that yeah you gotta go real
christmas trees unless there's like some
sort of allergy type
if unless there's like some extenuating
circumstance i can turn a blind eye
through
sure but you gotta go [ __ ] real tree
yeah and in new york too you even i get
that you got a small apartment whatever
but you can get the tiny little books
like we got one this year i did one two
years ago yeah yeah normally we get a
big full one
but we're not going to be there for
we're not going to be here for christmas
so we got a little one for the next
couple weeks it's a little cute look i
know
i've done that too they're so cute man
and the way we the way we look at it we
looked at it as most people don't get
the little christmas trees
so we look at it like it's a little
doggy like like a little um like a
rescue
it's a rescue tree that's what we call
it okay
um it didn't rescue me i rescued him
that's right whatever yeah that's right
she rescued us he also said this is also
from daddy dub fresh
uh sounds like a [ __ ] 90s rapper or
80s rapper him and cool
cool emoji or whatever third base
opening up for him
you ever go to your friend's house and
the food just ain't no good i'm daddy
dub fresh i'm here to say
ah
[Laughter]
also family reunions i mean we've kind
of talked about it before
wait is this daddy dub first second part
of the question yeah yeah yeah it's got
two in there
yeah fake christmas trees and what does
what do we think about family reunions
[ __ ] trap inherently garbage trucks
apparently trash we went to one as a kid
as a
i don't even know who started the family
was i never even seen any of them
[ __ ] again
we might have crashed someone else's
just for the [ __ ] hot dogs
i don't know who but i remember they
tried giving me a shirt and i was like
i ain't [ __ ] i don't know you [ __ ]
guys i ain't wearing this
that is the only thing that makes a
family reunion trash here is the
searching shirt
yeah we did blank we like i've said i
think i've said it before on i think it
was the brian six episode uh shout out
to beezer
um [ __ ] we do it on the beach in
wildwood with like no permits or
anything we just get down there early a
bunch of my [ __ ] mook cousins
set up tents at like 7am and stake out
the ground
with a bunch of empty chairs and stuff
and then it's like everybody brings food
and beers and we hang out it's a regular
beach day you're doing this yeah
oh god but they all vacation there so
it's like and you're allowed to do that
you love to set up tents and stuff like
that
i mean they're not like carnival tents
but they're like [ __ ] you know rides
for the kids
no they're like [ __ ] you know like
canopies like you would set up if you
had like a family you went down to the
beach like the coleman [ __ ] gotcha
you know what else is trashy too on the
flip side of that because we're not just
[ __ ] taking shots at people
low income rich people try to do this
but i think it's real trashy it might be
an east coast thing
might not be but people go down the
shore
and they take a family photo where
they're all wearing white
shirts all of my [ __ ] family [ __ ] you
and your white button down listen
we've all been dumb broad sister-in-law
that no one can stand
yeah shit's trash it's so [ __ ]
honorable every one of my cousins i
think all these babies
and there's always like the one of them
posing and like the casual one with the
dog like jumping in or something
it's like oh the impromptu yeah gotta
see it
no thanks i don't even like pictures to
begin with photos yeah you don't fit in
them
um you really support me in my weight
loss here i do
man what are you talking about through
negative reinforcement hey it worked for
me
worked for me what you don't know
negative reinforcement
punk you were smoking doobies under the
[ __ ] bleachers
here all-star athlete well whatever
happened back then
you're 400 pounds so you got to make
some zoom in on the jersey
we should have a jersey cam over there
let's check in with the jersey cam
and still hang it okay
have the jersey be the man on the street
shout out to the jersey 15 tackles his
senior year
is that the number no it's way more than
that oh i'm oh
i'm sorry leonlette
that's a deep cut i don't know why that
name came some old eagles
no leo i think he was the coquette one
of the cokeheads on the cowboys
i think leonleck got arrested with coke
like 15 times that could be wrong that's
awesome
um yeah um
this is from jessie bai um she says she
loves doing it but is it garbage
when you ask for the hanger when you buy
a shirt
oh my god
here's the thing it depends where you're
getting the shirt from
as far as i remember that's an even
trashier answer brooks brothers doesn't
give you the hat here when you're going
to buy a [ __ ] button down
but when i go to walmart and get my
[ __ ] george collection
because it's not worth it for them
they're all in plastic hangers but
here's the thing dude when they just
fold they just yeah dude walmart does
not care about folding the t-shirt
they wrap they put it all in a pile wrap
it up around their arm and shove it
up shove it in the bag yeah they don't
[ __ ] care yeah
but you got a good set of hangers out of
me you know what i mean have you ever
stolen hangers from anywhere
what where am i stealing hangers i don't
know hotel room
no all the hotels i have them all locked
on there your mob well we know what your
mom steals from [ __ ] hotel rooms
that's the first episode on patreon.com
foley's mom steals
everything and anything that's not
bolted down she's the reason they
[ __ ] drill the tv to the to the
dresser
she walked with a couple of those flat
screens flat screens are real light
let me tell you that i've walked with a
couple of zeniths back in the day
ooh shout out to patty mayo patty um
this is from matt a marlar matt marlar
how many sleeveless shirts do you own
and how many of them weren't originally
sleeveless
that's all i do you do sleeveless oh
sleeve i thought you meant like this
like short sleeve
i don't [ __ ] with the long sleeve button
down like that my forearms out
in case [ __ ] goes down in the street
plus they're not comfortable
they're tight here um no sleeveless
shirts because i
in my younger days yes but i have
developed
um skin tags skin tags
is skin tags is one but do you ever
notice the middle-aged fat guy that
wears a short sleeve shirt
and you can see the side and the and the
stretch marks and you just know it
doesn't look fresh your paw print
tattoos
it doesn't look fresh and it doesn't
look clean so it's not a good look i was
always jealous
of right because i was always i was a
bigger i was a i was a big guy
right and now i'm a bigger you know i've
lost some weight i'm just you know
you're a fat kid
i was a fat kid all the big head with a
big head right
uh tiny pee pee bad haircut yeah bad
haircut you said it was looking good
today though
who did you no i said you had a lot of
product in there i don't think so
you were going for it you get
something's going on no absolutely
nothing and it looks like you got a
little bit of that spray in there would
you get that
[ __ ] fake christmas tree stuff dude
it looks like the snow
coat that i thought about that now that
we got these new hd cams though
doing a little [ __ ] crop duster up
top
got the hair of a cartoon character
just one line right here that's
patreon.com
no i uh i was always
jealous of the fat guy who had like a
tight
body a little bit i'm flabby i've always
been
do you ever see like there's like the
fat guy i take his shirt off and it
looks like he's just like
blown up a little bit he's not like
jiggling the hard stuff the heart that's
like
like a burp chrysler you go like oh that
like he looks okay because it's not
jiggle it and or he looks better than
most i'll tell you who the epitome
of that is is uh it's gonna be somewhat
of a deep cut but if you saw the
irishman
uh there's a there's an actor in there
named bo dietl he used to be
yeah he used to be a cop he became an
actor he also just ran for mayor a
couple couple years ago he tries every
year
yeah he he is he's fat also the way you
said that ran for me
he ran for me or a couple of years ago
he's heavy but he's sexy
you know what i mean like paul hollywood
is a bigger guy but i bet he looks good
without his shirt off
british baking show you know i'm talking
he's tight he's not a bigger guy you
don't think he's smaller than like he's
like stockier but
that's leaning into what you're talking
about i know exactly what i don't have
like i never i i'm not a good fat no
some guys are like
they got it tight and they can do the
cut off i couldn't do the cut off
because you got the jiggle
yeah [ __ ] i always wanted to or a lot of
times a fat guy because on the beach you
know what i mean especially when you're
younger it's like a lot of fat guys
would do like just the basketball jersey
and i'm like that looks pretty good like
i could never pull it off though
jump shot was terrible
[Applause]
this guy had no left
i kept double dribbling getting snuffed
left and right
yeah that's a trash uh the sleeveless
shirts i don't do
but this is a tip i want to give you and
you this is a
uh when you go to like a wedding
or something or you know you're like you
got to wear a suit say
to do and you wear like a white shirt
under the suit your nipples show your
chest hair
it's so it's tough because that those
dress shirts are very thin but then when
you do
if you do the wife beater they see the
wife beater i know exactly what you're
gonna say
okay let me finish uh but if you do a
t-shirt
you see the [ __ ] sleeve mark you look
like a [ __ ] jamock when you're trying
to do the electric slide on a dance
floor
and so you get a what
go ahead no you get a regular t-shirt
and cut the sleeves off
that way it's solid here you don't see
and then the sleeves go on the crease
where the crease is
they don't know that you don't so you
don't see the sleeve at all it's [ __ ]
phenomenal see my brother turned me onto
that one time i was like what are you
doing he goes
check this out my we're in a hotel room
my mind was blown
i was like get me the scissors stat
daddy oh we're taking we're taking these
sleeves off
kippy's rocking the guns i also heard if
you get a light
gill-like gray you don't see it as much
through the through the white shirt but
the sleeves are dead
you see the sleeves that we're halfway
down this yeah
i told you one time on my brother's uh i
was always like the idiot who like i was
a fat kid so like i never
had cult like i never had like real good
dress clothes you know i mean it was
always kind of like what i pieced
together
or what fit at that time of the year or
whatever a lot of runs to tj maxx last
minute to get
a [ __ ] shirt or khakis that fit
whatever i was always missing one
crucial
article of closure sure um and i bought
a [ __ ] short i didn't i went to polo
down on like brawled in walnut
because it was against dress rehearsal
writing it was his wedding weekend so we
were staying at the hotel for the
weekend down there
uh and i was like i'll just stop at polo
grab a [ __ ] shirt for 60 bucks
must be nice all pinned up i only had
like 100 bucks in my account at the time
still do
the envelope like uh he didn't get one
uh your brother
no you think him an envelope no i just
what do you mean you say that like i'm
an [ __ ]
yeah we don't do we me and him don't do
that you and him don't do what
especially at that time i was probably
we were working together it was yeah i
just
you know he didn't get him a what he
didn't give a number to what even i gave
my brother an envelope
and i was [ __ ] all yacked up do you
give your siblings christmas presents no
no no shot no you don't no [ __ ] no
the [ __ ] are you commies what are you
talking about we gotta understand
yeah i have a good relationship with my
brother that we don't need to [ __ ]
fake pleasantries and hand them a
sweater or something
also we were working together at that
time we were taking my dad's we were
taking my dad's business over so it's
like money was tight we're gonna be like
hey i took 500
out of the [ __ ] corporate account to
give to you that we're going to need to
cover payroll next week
like what you know what i mean that
doesn't make sense i always get my
brother a nice christmas present
uh tim that's so i understand it i'm not
but to me and like the relationship i
have with my bro
it's like so fake to me buy him a
present
what yeah hey i got this for you because
i love you
and i thought you would enjoy it and
it's the holiday season what present do
you get your brother
bottle a nice bottle of scotch a good
book that he's that he likes you know
something like that what book
i don't know a book about ronald reagan
or something like that whatever
it's different every year i yeah i don't
know a world war ii book that he's been
you know he wants to read or something
okay but then what do you have
conversations like hey what do you uh
how do you find out what book he wants
to read what do you think what
do you what would you like for christmas
this year big guy that's insane to me
the fact that you're asking them
what do you want me to buy you that's
insane to me
hey what do you want for christmas this
year save the 40 bucks and go buy the
bottle or
the book yourself asking for a specific
christmas present
is so trashy it's insane who the [ __ ]
are you what's going on here
dude you're asking your 42 year old
brother how
is he older or younger than you he's
older you're asking your older brother
you're
pushing how old are you 44. so your
brother's pushing 50. he's 46
46. you're asking him hey what can i get
you that's under 40 bucks that i can buy
you
and you're the one that added 40 bucks
yeah cause i'm trying to be funny relax
why are you so offensive about this
because you're [ __ ] on giving
christmas presents which i think is a
good night's thing
okay i'm just saying i still i mean for
two grown men
to exchange presents i mean you're not
spending 500 bucks on them
i might one year sure someday but you
haven't i could
if i wanted to no you couldn't i made it
patreon.com
stop with the patreon it's a joke what
are you doing
relax why you're so butthurt that we're
waking funny that you buy your brother a
[ __ ] christmas present
no it's not that you are you're i am
i am shocked that you don't get
christmas presents for you
i'm sorry i'm just [ __ ] i'm sharing that
the relationship i have with my brother
that is just that seems very fake to me
he'd be like oh fake here's a sweater oh
here's a bottle of
scotch i don't it just it seems
especially after i asked him hey do you
think what can i buy you this
do you think it's fake if you give your
niece and nephew a christmas present
no because they're children uh would you
give your mother a christmas present
yeah do you think that's fake no
but also it's like she's not asking for
yeah it's a little
it's a little heartless a little bit
yeah why
so it's less heartless to give them
nothing i don't
who to my brother i mean my mom's
different yeah we're talking about my
brother
my grown man brother to be like oh
here's
a bottle of kettle one or something that
you probably have i just
or i don't know or even ask him is
crazier to me really
yeah do you you don't buy your your
siblings gifts do you
no no no no yeah when did it stop uh
when he
got drunk when he drove over the course
yeah you got [ __ ] damn you're talking
about me
you guys are damaged so so he got he got
drunk and wanted to like flex on me that
he was making money and i wasn't
so he dropped like three grand into my
bank account
ah like hammered just to just to show
that he could do it and then he was like
awesome hey it's a great brother yeah
except for the next day when he asked if
i would send it back oh
what the [ __ ] yeah minus a little
shipping and handling oh yeah there was
a little bit of a
dollar yeah there's a venmo fee it came
back
no i don't i don't know i just i i don't
i yeah it's just it's it's empty it's
empty gestures to me i'd rather hang out
with my brother
i'm not saying you don't i'm just saying
to me i'd rather like get together and
[ __ ] have a moment with my brother
than go
oh here or here it's just i don't know
it sounds like you're being a cheapo
if you ask me not at all we decided when
we were like [ __ ] 17 to be like this
is just
fake what are we doing yeah fake i don't
know maybe it's though
i'm getting hung up on the world why is
it fake to give your brother or sister
i'm saying in my
relationship with my brother that would
be viewed as
it's i it's to ask him what he wants is
very disingenuous so he didn't get him
anything because i'm not doing it
you didn't get him anything for his
wedding i didn't get many things i
haven't got him i haven't given my
brother a gift since we were like
and like we had to no for christmas i
get something from the kids like a
shirt or something like that like hey
this is from you know the kids
but it's like we don't exchange presents
okay i don't want to ruin the fun
forever we do have a guest coming in
shortly
all right yeah yeah i i do have uh a
question from instagram mm-hmm from her
old pal
brian morton sure in chicago shout out
to bee man
love him to death uh have you ever
used a poster or picture to cover up a
hole in your wall
what at the house yeah for sure
first i don't know that i put there yeah
i don't know if i've ever intentionally
like gone out and bought a picture but
i've been like well we can move that
over here to cover that up
yeah i'm not i'm not married to it on
the north side wall like
it can definitely go on this side of the
wall yeah i punched a hole in the door
uh in my old apartment so trashy that
then i didn't think anybody would notice
and then we were after we moved like a
week later i saw that door out there
landing by the train did you get
did you get knocked forward on the
security deposit nah you want to know
why
because i made sure i took care of the
super because we were moving out
always thanks for everything yeah bada
boom bada
all sudden that paperwork gets lost i
had a i had a bedroom door that wouldn't
lock in the apartment i lived in
uh because i got i'd we had a party and
i locked my the door to my bedroom so i
would go in
[ __ ] with my [ __ ] got hammered drunk
couldn't find the guy oh always
and then like i had a no knock ward i
just [ __ ] busted him
got the [ __ ] sledgehammer start
[ __ ] throwing heat
that's awesome yeah for sure that's
always happened at every place i moved
out there's been a [ __ ] up door or
something oranges
a closet door or something oh yeah um
guys that's it
thank you so much what a fun time thank
you so much for writing in we appreciate
it so much
i appreciate all the support it's
[ __ ] fantastic
check out uh i'm on social media at uh
kevinrandcomedy on all social media
like we said go to the patreon
podcastmarch.com you can get yourself a
t-shirt
uh yeah we appreciate the support uh
youtube
for full hd video ranking out there
twice a week
go subscribe you comment we try to reply
to all the comments and stuff like that
it's a good time
check it out thank you and each foley on
ice
would you you cut it no you just [ __ ]
you just froze it was like somebody
pulled a gun on you
dude you [ __ ] it was like because
you're in the headlights i thought you
were like taking your hands
no you went i'm out of trouble [ __ ]
somebody get this guy at a great price
foley on ice on twitter foldygrams on
instagram we love you guys and we'll see
you next week peace